على وزير الخارجيه الروسيه ان الغرب يامل
في الحق هزيمه جيو استراتيجيه بروسيا
مضيفا ان ما يحدث في اوكرانيا الان هو
معركه جيو سياسيه مع الغرب ايضا رفض في
لقائه مع محطه روسيا 24 ما وصفها بالمزاعم
الغربيه بان موسكو ترفض التفاوض بشان
اوكرانيا
ترفض التفاوض بشان اوكرانيا هي مزاعم
كاذبه الغرب يقول ان نتيجه الحرب يجب ان
تكون هزيمه روسيا بالحجم الذي لا تستطيع
بعده على مدى عقود طويله استعاده اقتصادها
فعليا نحن الان في قلب معركه جيوسياسيه مع
الغرب
كما توعد وزير الخارجيه الروسيه بابعاد
الاسلحه التي وعد بها الغرب اوكرانيا عن
الحدود الروسيه
هذا التصعيد مثل كره الثلج بدا بخودات
للجيش الاوكراني ثم ظهرت اسلحه صغيره
والان يتحدثون عن الطائرات فكلما تم توفير
مزيد من الاسلحه بعيده المدى لنظام
ازدادت ضروره ابعادها اكثر عن الاراضي
التي تعد جزءا من بلادنا